en el vídeo pasado estuvimos analizando
las ecuaciones x igual a 3 veces el
coste no dt y igual a dos veces el seno
de t y decíamos que eran un par de
ecuaciones paramétricas en este tipo de
ecuaciones utilizando la identidad de
hoy leer llegamos a una una elipse a la
forma de una elipse si x cuadrada entre
9 + 10 cuadrada entre 4 es igual a 1
espero que ustedes acuerden si no se
acuerdan sería muy bueno que revisaran
el vídeo anterior ahora bien ya que
teníamos eso nosotros gráfica mos la
elipse y nos dábamos cuenta que si
queríamos dar muchas vueltas en la
elipse entonces el tiempo estaba entre
menos infinito e infinito y solamente
queríamos dar una vuelta del elipse pues
el tiempo estaba entre 0 y 2 pi también
fue en el vídeo pasado en el cual
hicimos una eliminación de parámetros y
llegamos así a la ecuación de la elipse
bien se cuenta que la ecuación de elipse
ya no aparece el parámetro t y sin
embargo aunque nos quedaba la ecuación
de una elipse el tiempo nos decía como
recordamos la elipse y en qué sentido
recordamos la elipse dicho de otra
manera el parámetro tiempo nos ayuda a
dar una sensación de espacio tiempo
como yo lo decía en unos vídeos pasados
para cada punto en mi elipse va a
existir un tiempo en el cual yo voy a
estar en ese punto de la elipse elimina
el parámetro tiempo nos ayuda a
dibujarlo sin embargo el tiempo nos da
una sensación de como recorremos nuestra
gráfica pero la pregunta de este vídeo
va a ser estas son las únicas ecuaciones
que me dan de una gráfica a una elipse
es decir solamente con estas ecuaciones
paramétricas yo puedo dibujar una elipse
pues imagínense que yo tengo x igualdad
tres veces el coseno y voy a modificar
un poco el ángulo va a ser 2 t y que va
a ser igual a dos veces el seno y
también de dos t ok y en el vídeo pasado
lo que nosotros hicimos era despejar al
coseno de t aquí vamos a hacer lo mismo
para el cosiendo de 2t entonces pues
aquí me estorba el 3 y por lo tanto lo
voy a pasar del otro lado dividiendo x
entre 3 es igual al coseno de 2 t
y de aquí pues voy a hacer lo mismo con
el seno de 2 te voy a pasar el 2
dividiendo y me va a quedar que entre 2
es igual al seno de 2 t
y espero que también ustedes acuerden
que en el vídeo pasado utilizamos la
famosísima identidad trigonométricas de
oier que dice que el seno cuadrado de t
más el coste no cuadrado de t es igual a
1 siempre es igual a 1 y de aquí
sustituimos entonces aquí pues también
lo voy a ocupar esta identidad de
econométrica se cumple para todos pues
también se va a cumplir para el seno de
2 t seno cuadrado de dos temas coseno
cuadrado de dos t es igual a 1 ojo esto
es porque la identidad de
trigonométricas de oilers se cumple para
cualquier ángulo para todos los ángulos
muy bien entonces utilizando esta
identidad trigonométricas de hoy les voy
a sustituir alcocer no es de 2 t al 100
donde 2 t para ver que obtengo entonces
el cocino de 2 trx entre 3 y si
sustituyó me va a quedar pues que els
coseno al cuadrado pues es x entre 3 al
cuadrado que es éste y entonces el seno
cuadrado es de entre 2 al cuadrado que
es este bien pongámoslo y entre 2
elevado al cuadrado
coseno cuadrado de los teques x entre 3
elevado al cuadrado muy bien y esto lo
voy a igualar a 1 y de aquí voy a hacer
los cuadrados y de una vez despejar
entonces va a quedar que x cuadrada
entre 9 porque es el cuadrado del coseno
cuadrado más ye cuadrada entre 4 que es
el cuadrado del seno cuadrado es igual a
1 y que creen tenemos la misma elipse la
misma elipse es esta y está dicho de
otra manera las dos pares de cuestiones
paramétricas me dan el mismo camino de
mi elipse pero entonces se pregunta será
cuál es la diferencia entre mis primeras
ecuaciones paramétricas y mis segundas
ecuaciones paramétricas bien como
hicimos en el vídeo pasado agarramos las
ecuaciones paramétricas que están en
azul e hicimos una tabla con ellas para
ver cómo se gráfica van los puntos y
además como recordamos es elipse pues
voy a hacer lo mismo está en esta
ocasión pero ahora con mis otras
ecuaciones paramétricas las voy a
apuntar aquí y era x igualdad tres veces
el coche no de dos t y que igual da dos
veces el seno de dos t y de nuevo voy a
hacer una tabla
bien en este caso voy a hacer otra vez
tres columnas y en una de ellas pondré
ate en otra de ellas pondré a x y en
otra de ellas pondré allí y para ver qué
es lo que pasa voy a tomar los mismos
valores de te voy a tomarte igual a 0 de
igualdad y medios y te iguala pi bien
ahora voy a sustituir las los valores de
t azules en las ecuaciones azules
oscuros bien entonces si te vale 0 pues
el coche no de 231 por 33 y a ver qué
pasa si spri medios pues pri medios por
2 espn y el coche no de pi es igual a
menos 1 y por 3 es menos 3 y ahora sí
pongo pi pues es cocinar dos piques uno
y tres por uno estrés si x vale 3
entonces te va a valer para maxim al
revés si te vale pide entonces x valdrá
3 bien que va a pasar ahora con gem
si tengo cero pues me queda que el seno
de 00 y por lo que sea pues es cero
ahora pi medios dos por medios speed
seno de pie cero otra vez y dos por cero
cero y si pongo pues me queda 2
dos dedos pies cero y pues otra vez cero
dándome así a una colección de ceros en
bien bien ahora voy a comparar lo que me
salió en mis puntos en mis primeras
ecuaciones paramétricas con los puntos
que me salieron en mis segundas
ecuaciones paramétricas pero si se
acuerdan en mis primeras de cuestiones
paramétricas lo que yo hacía al evaluar
mis puntos era darme la idea de cómo
recorría yo mi elipse phillips y la
recorría en contra de las manecillas del
reloj le daba vueltas de izquierda de
derecha a izquierda bien a ver entonces
yo tenía que estaba en el primer nivel
donde te valía cero y en mis primeras
ecuaciones paramétricas me salía este
punto después si yo sustituya a t igual
a pi medios entonces obtenía el punto de
acá y por último si yo sustituya a p
igualdad pi entonces en las primeras
ecuaciones paramétricas me daba este
punto lo que me daba la sensación de
recorrer mi elipses de derecha a
izquierda
entonces yo podría decir que mi elipse
le iba a recorrer siempre de derecha a
izquierda dando una infinidad de vueltas
ahora qué pasará si yo comparo los
puntos que no salieron en mis segundas
ecuaciones paramétricas con mis primeras
ecuaciones paramétricas pues en el
primer punto me da el mismo punto entre
igual a cero estoy empezando en el mismo
punto digo no forzosamente tenemos que
empezar en cero podemos empezar en
cualquier número menos dos y menos 5 p -
infinito lo importante de este ejercicio
es que estamos comparando los dos puntos
que nos sale de mis primeras ecuaciones
paramétricas y mis segundas ecuaciones
paramétricas bien ahora que va a ser
comprime dios en prime dios teníamos
este de aquí en nuestras segundas
ecuaciones paramétricas no sería el
punto menos 30 o sea éste lo voy a poner
aquí changos es del mismo color verde
mejor que voy a cambiar a morado para
que se vea la diferencia bien aquí
morado entonces cuando nosotros íbamos
en el primer en las primeras ecuaciones
paramétricas de cero api medios y vamos
de aquí hasta acá y vamos del 30 al 0.2
ahora qué pasa si nosotros nos vemos de
0 a pri medios en las segundas
ecuaciones paramétricas pues vamos a
recorrer desde aquí desde este punto
hasta el punto de acá estamos
recorriendo todo esto todo esto en mis
segundas ecuaciones paramétricas del
punto 30 al punto menos 30 vamos en la
misma dirección pero ahora estamos
recorriendo la elipse un poco más rápido
bien qué pasaba si nosotros recordamos
de imprime dios hapy pues bueno teníamos
el punto 0 2 al menos 30 hacíamos este
recorrido y ahora si nosotros recorremos
depp y medios up y en mis segundas
ecuaciones paramétricas recorremos toda
la otra mitad de la elipse se dan cuenta
con esto estoy enseñándoles que yo
recorro mucho más rápido con mis
segundas ecuaciones paramétricas que
consumidas ecuaciones paramétricas de
hecho no más rápido dos veces más rápido
si es que darse cuenta en mi primera
cambio de tiempo de cero a pi medios en
mis primeras ecuaciones paramétricas
recorría un cuarto de la elipse mientras
que en mis segundas ecuaciones
paramétricas yo recorría la mitad de la
elipse wow esto quiere decir que tengo
dos pares de ecuaciones paramétricas las
cuales me dan el mismo camino pero
recorren de maneras distintas mi elipse
mi camino
también aquí está otra prueba muy
importante de por qué el parámetro nos
da mucha información acerca de mis
ecuaciones paramétricas si yo veo cómo
se recorría una ecuación paramétrica y
la otra ecuación paramétrica no era lo
mismo de hecho si yo le pongo un menos
aquí al late y otro menos aquí en late
aquí uno menos y aquí otro menos lo que
haría es recorrer mi gráfica de la
manera contraria es decir en lugar de en
contra de las manecillas del reloj la
recogería a favor de las manecillas del
reloj pero ahora la pregunta es
supongamos que me dicen sal yo tengo
esta ecuación de la elipse yo me podría
regresar a mis ecuaciones paramétricas y
la respuesta es no no me puedo regresar
a mis ecuaciones paramétricas si a mí me
dan la ecuación de la elipse yo ya perdí
información y no sabría si podría
regresar a estas ecuaciones paramétricas
a las primeras oa estas ecuaciones
paramétricas a las segundas o de hecho a
cualquiera ecuación paramétrica que
tenga una forma similar es decir yo si
tengo esta ecuación de mi elipse no
sabría si me voy a tres coseno de t
3 coseno de 2 tx3 coseno de lo que sea
de lo que sea te voy a ponerle aquí rayo
no es lo que sea te y jay igual a tres
veces el seno de lo que sea t
pero si lo que sea y lo que sea son
iguales es muy importante yo no podría
saber si regreso a esta ecuación
paramétrica oa las otras ecuaciones
paramétricas oa cualquier ecuación
paramétrica de esta forma entonces si a
mí me dan la ecuación de la elipse yo
estoy perdiendo información es por eso
que las ecuaciones paramétricas nos dan
mucha información acerca de cómo
recorremos una gráfica pero bueno habrá
forma de que si yo les doy una función
de x una función de x cualquiera no sé
se me ocurre la función ye igual a x
cuadrada más x la que sea realmente ante
la importancia y yo les doy una ecuación
paramétrica no sé supongamos que les doy
la ecuación
a ver una difícil se me ocurre la idea
de x de t una función que depende de
solamente una ecuación paramétrica no 2
una ecuación paramétrica a la ecuación x
dt que sea igual a pues algo que tengan
que ver con t algo como el coseno de
aguas y difícil coseno de t y a esto le
voy a restar el logaritmo natural de t
bien ya tengo mis dos ecuaciones
paramétricas no una ecuación de que
depende de xy una ecuación paramétrica a
pues yo puedo encontrar ahora me entra
ecuación paramétrica pues la respuesta
es que sí sin sustituyó a x pues ya cabe
lo podrías decir que es igual al coseno
de tm en su lugar y no natural de todo
esto elevado al cuadrado más equis pero
x es el coseno dt menos el logaritmo
natural de t esto se ve un poco difícil
pero me ayuda a solamente decirles lo
que les quiero contar supongamos que
ahora yo pongo otra parametrización
supongamos que ahora yo digo que x es
igual a t pues entonces tendríamos que
ya es igualdad de cuadrada más te una y
otras no tienen nada que ver en un
principio no tienen nada que ver pero lo
que sí tienen que ver es que como es la
misma
de x vamos a recorrer la misma gráfica
solamente que de maneras distintas
si yo graficar a esto que graficar esto
es una parábola no siguió gráfica esta
función de x y ocupó una parametrización
y otra parametrización realmente lo que
estoy haciendo son gráficas iguales pero
recorriendo las de maneras distintas por
ejemplo voy a hacer una gráfica aquí
nueva no va a ser ni esta ni la otra o
sea no va a ser una parábola va a ser
una gráfica nueva la que se me ocurra
voy a tomar estos dos ejes coordenadas
este es xy este game y ahora voy a hacer
un círculo por aquí este círculo ojo
este círculo no tiene nada que ver con
estas ecuaciones que estoy dibujando del
lado izquierdo lo que sí quiero
contarles ejercicio hay una
parametrización antes después de
recorrer el círculo de derecha a
izquierda mientras que si yo doy otra
parametrización yo pueda recorrer el
círculo de izquierda a derecha y también
podríamos encontrar otra parametrización
que recorriera de derecha a izquierda el
círculo y de izquierda a derecha a su
vez de hecho la única diferencia entre
esta ecuación paramétrica azul y esta
amarilla es que va a recorrer mi gráfica
de una manera distinta
tal vez una de derecha a izquierda la
otra de izquierda a derecha la otra de
una manera distinta pero son formas de
recuerda es la distinta espero les haya
servido este vídeo